Nakamura laughed shook his head in
disbelief and a logged off Fabiano
caruana had just delivered Maiden one
and booked his ticket to the winners
bracket final in the chessable Masters
the day began with a convincing Victory
by Magnus Carlsen as black over Wesley
so a quick draw with white secured the
match Victory keeping Carlson's hopes
alive in the elimination bracket he
advances to tomorrow's losers bracket
semifinals where he will face levona
ronian who won his match against
vladislav artemiev in Armageddon the big
action-packed match of the day was the
All-American winners bracket final it
was an absolute slugfest and in game one
Carolina got the better of Nakamura when
Hikaru overpressed with his attack and
could not Checkmate fabi's fleeing King
in the next game Carolina was extremely
close to a second Victory but the always
slippery Hikaru escaped in the end game
Carolina Clint down on the light squares
in the third game but it looked as
though Hikaru had reached another drawn
in-game when he blundered allowing
Fabiano to end the game on the spot